de donde se enviarán las postales de las
próximas vacaciones será desde playas
vacías o llenas
parís roma barcelona o las islas griegas
podrán volver a turistas pronto
la unión europea ha dicho que creará
certificados verdes para permitir el
libre movimiento dentro de sus fronteras
esto servirá como prueba de que una
persona ha sido vacunada contra el coi
19 tiene un resultado negativo reciente
o se recuperó del virus pero en el mejor
de los casos el certificado sólo estará
disponible desde junio los países que
dependen del turismo como italia están
impacientes los hoteles están vacíos
pero esperan que los certificados de
vacunación sean la solución ideal donde
la ayudaría a devolverle la confianza a
la gente en el turismo y creo que debe
ocurrir rápido porque cada día es un día
perdido
por ahora algunas naciones han empezado
a implementar iniciativas locales aquí
en berlín a los visitantes se les hace
una prueba antes de entrar a este museo
la medida les da seguridad a las
personas y al director de la institución
estamos felices nos ha permitido reabrir
y nos da confianza en el futuro
[Música]
estas perspectivas
pero qué pasará con los turistas que
vienen de lugares fuera del bloque como
reino unido- por ejemplo
por ahora están excluidos de los futuros
certificados verdes y cada país de la
unión podrá imponer sus propias reglas
pero el bloque está trabajando con la
organización mundial de la salud para
garantizar que el certificado sea
reconocido fuera de sus fronteras